this is the 970 non XT it's supposed to
be $550 for MSRP at least the XT is $600
so that makes the XT about 9% more
expensive they are really close to each
other for pricing it it looks kind of
like an upsell but the 970 actually
remains really interesting on its own
and it's not actually for a reason that
we expected it's not even because it
stands up really well when you put it
down that way although that is quite
impressive first of all in some of our
efficiency tests when looking at
performance per watt it nearly tied for
the most efficient GPU this seems to be
in the so-called sweet spot of power and
performance in what would be a huge
upset favoring AMD the fact that it's
starting to chip away at one of nvidia's
key areas of competition is huge the
reason for that is simply because the
970 pulls a lot less power than the 970
XT by percentage but most of the
performance remains and so for the
quickest possible version of the
performance between these two cards the
970 XT versus the 970 in our testing has
the XT model in the range of 9 to 16%
better at 4K and 1440p rasterized again
against the 9070 typically it's about 11
to 133% in the game swe we did I think
we did 10 games uh rasterized and then
we did another site with rt at 1080p it
is 6% to 15% better for the XT versus
the non-xt mostly around 9 to 11% uh for
the games we tested now as for the 5070
it's not looking good for NVIDIA not
that it looked good for NVIDIA when they
got on stage and said this 490
performance at at
549 that really was the nail in the
coffin before the 5070 even launched
except this time Jensen Juan was holding
the hammer I guess anyway versus
nvidia's RTX card you shouldn't buy at
4K and Riz the 970 leads the 570 by 0 to
18% depending on the game it has one
loss in Final Fantasy and it has losses
in some rate tracing test but not all of
them that's also interesting the 507 is
basically out of the conversation so at
this point we're left with the
discussion of the 970 XT versus the 970
which is probably what AMD wants that is
what Nvidia wants cuz Nvidia has done
Nvidia minus $50 for like all of its
pricing where it has a card every 50 to
100 bucks uh AMD meanwhile has switched
from Nvidia minus $50 to AMD minus $50
so uh that makes this a different
discussion than it might otherwise have
been now this might be partly due to
yields if they're yielding enough that
the XT is readily available and they
want to create an upsell that might be a
motive for it we don't really care what
the reasoning is it's irrelevant to us
what we care about is as a consumer
which one should you buy and really does
it doesn't make any sense uh to either
spend the extra 50 or save the extra 50
depending on which one you're looking at
so that's all we really care about here
and that's what we're going to get into
today so let's get to the review before
that this video is brought to you by the
montac hyperflow series of liquid
coolers the montac hyperflow aims to
compete with other affordable liquid
coolers by fighting on price to
Performance and our tasting cooler
performance was comparable to others in
its class the argb hyperflow has an
illuminated pump block with RGB LED fans
that have quality rubber bumpers for
vibration damping the cooler has a
six-year warranty and supports all
modern Intel and AMD sockets and you can
learn more at the link in the
description below all right so this
one's going to be pretty simple we're
not going to spend a lot of time with
the architecture today or really the
comparisons they won't be as long as in
the XT review so if you want the full
sort of discussion of the comparisons
then go to the 970 XT review we'll link
that below and if you want the full
discussion of the architecture so this
is things like changes to the actual
what's going on in the block diagram
changes to the r tracing stuff like that
check out our news piece on the rdna 4
announcement that'll be linked below as
well uh this one we're kind of going for
the speedrun here for a few reasons one
is we just talked about the 970 XD a lot
of that information matches with the
9070 except for the performance and the
second reason is I haven't gotten to
sleep because there's non-stop Hardware
chaos or launches I mean it's a good
problem to have I love working on this
stuff it's been a really fun week but
also uh I am going to die so I need to
get through this review and then sleep
but it's a really interesting card the
basics architecturally match the XT so
the 9070 still benefits from the rate
tracing changes that amds made that was
the sort of biggest area they focused on
in their gaming discussion the 970 has
56 compute units with the 970 XT running
64 both are 16 GB cards with gdr 6 on a
256bit bus the gpus have slightly
different clocks the architectural
overhauls of rdna for match so the same
changes apply to the 970 as the XT again
with sort of the main exception mean
that 50 60u versus 64 that's really sort
of it it's very simple setup this time
now pricing we're not going to bother
going through alternative cards right
now because there's really just three
that are in the discussion today for a
card in this class of price it's going
to be the 5070 which you shouldn't buy
the 970 XT and the 9070 and then Intel
they're like kind of starting to get
closer but not for the right reason so
the b580 is supposed to be a $250 card
maybe 300 with a partner model it's in
like the 400 sometimes and you shouldn't
buy it for that price unfortunately uh
very interesting card at 250 though
they're super competitive actually at
that price but anyway we're going to get
straight into the data we'll save some
of the pricing recap and Alternatives
and comparing all the cards available
after this launch clears so we're going
to give it a couple days come back and
revisit post launch which just cuz we
want to monitor the next day or two get
an idea for the availability of both the
570 and the 970 series and then uh look
at the pricing once it kind of hits the
street so we get the actual Street
pricing uh but for now we have to work
off of MSRP for comparisons because the
only fixed comparison we have until we
can see what this price is at let's get
straight into the data Dragon stock with
2 is up first and at 4K initially in
this test the RX 97 non XT ran at 64 FPS
average with lows at 54 and 53 the 970
xt's 70 FPS result positions at 9% ahead
which is exactly how much higher the
base MSRP is against the equivalently
priced RTX 570 this is one of amd's
stronger titles the 970 pulse leads the
570 fe's 56 FPS average by 14% here with
1% and. 1% lows improved in step with
the average the 970 is achieving 87% of
the performance of the 55070 ti but at
73% of the base MSRP the RX 970 leads
the RX 7800 XT by 37% here as well and
we'll look at the 6700 XT elsewhere at
14 40p the RX 970 ran at 106 FPS average
with the 970 XT leading it at 116 or
9.3% ahead the 5070 TI is only a few FPS
higher than the 970 XT with the 480
super just beyond that in short the 970
is achieving 88% of the 480 supers
performance which was a $11,000 card but
the 970 is at 55% of the original MSRP
despite our wishes that the 970 were $50
cheaper this at least helps to slowly
reset the runaway pricing that Nvidia
set in motion it gives everyone some
perspective of no we should not be
paying $11,000 for that for some
comparisons against prior Generations
the 970 improves on the 67 FPS result of
the 7700 XT by 59% the 53 FPS result of
the 6700 XT which was a very popular
card for them by 100% And the 42 FPS of
the 6600 XT by 15 52% here's 1080p the
old GTX 1060 and 1070 also appear on
this chart to give you some insight into
upgrades although anything modern would
be better than those it's still helpful
to see them on the charts there's no
point in putting percentages in for them
though because they go from unplayable
to playable the RX 970 is about tied
with the 700 XT the 970 XT still leads
by around 8% with the 5070 TI ahead of
the 970 by 133% the 970 leads the RTX
570 DOA Edition by 6% and the lead over
the 6700 XT is 96% with the Improvement
on the 6600 non xt's 49 FPS result at
173% Final Fantasy 14 Dawn Trail is up
now we included this same disclaimer and
disclosure in our 9070 XT review but to
recap it we've noticed lower performance
for the 970 series specifically in Final
Fantasy 14 Dawn Trail including lower
results than amd's own claims we've had
highly reliable results in this
Benchmark and R 970 series data has been
repeatable across multiple tests so it
doesn't really matter what the first
party data from its presentation says
we're publishing it but we just want to
highlight that there is a
disproportionately low performance for
the 970s and that's something that we're
investigating it's possible that it
could be the specific scene maybe the
Benchmark version or just the
architector behavior here naturally but
the results is repeatable and so we're
running them at 4K the 970 continues the
scaling pattern set by the 970 XT the XT
is again 9% ahead the 5070 Fe leads both
of the cards in this test running
running at 78 FPS average and improving
upon the 970s result of 63 FPS by 24%
against the prior generation the 970 XT
sees a smaller Improvement on the 6700
XT of 53% at 1440p the 970 ran at 126
FPS average the 970 XT is 10% ahead here
with the 570 ahead by 21% improvement
over the last generation is non-existent
with the S 800 XT right next to the 970
now as we said in the XT review we
checked in with de Bower and saw similar
results to some of his tests so it does
appear to be a behavior that is related
to the game engine and the API and
things like that moving on Resident Evil
4 is up next tested at 4K first the 970
ran at 91 FPS average here creating a
13% lead for the 970 XT and it's one 3
FPS result the 970 XT was excitingly
right next to the 480 supers 105 FPS in
this game meaning that the same $1,000
480 super result leads the $550 MSRP 97
7 by only 16% that is a poultry gain for
such a huge price difference especially
given how new the 480 super is amd's 970
exceeds the performance of the same MSRP
RTX 570 78 FPS by 16% if Nvidia would
stop remaking 4070 supers and 480s they
might actually make some progress here
but until they do the memes will
continue until the products improve and
now I realize it's too much now yes the
the only thing that's too much Jensen is
the amount of 4070 supers and 480s at
1440p the RX 970 ran at72 FPS average
and outperformed the 390 TI the 970 XT
outperforms the 970 by 133% with the 570
TI only slightly beyond that result
against the 570 is 152 FPS average the
970 runs 13% ahead the 570 really does
look even more deway than previously in
some of these tests if that were
possible if it were a dead horse it'd be
getting kicked right now 1080p is up now
the 970 ran at 247 FPS average here
which had it between the 470 TI and the
470 TI super the 570 still Trails now
giving the 970 lead of 10% the XT model
maintains about a 12% advantage over the
non XT black myth Ukon is a much more
challenging title for AMD to run but
mostly with raay tracing either way
there should be some more favor for
NVIDIA here even without RT it's a heavy
game The Rage tracing test will come a
little bit later but let's look at 4K
and rasterized the 70 ran at 41 FPS
average against the 970 XTS 46 giving
the latter a lead of 11% the 700 XTX
sits just ahead of the 970 XT the 970
ends up still leading the RTX 570 albeit
on a technicality which is actually a
huge victory for AMD in this particular
title that'll change with rt but this is
a good position overall of raster at
1440p the 970 held 75 FPS average with
well paced lows sitting at 65 and 60 FPS
for 1% and 0.1% this is consistent and
good for frame time pacing but it's also
about the same as all of its neighbors
so it's nothing exceptional the 570 ran
at 72.1 FPS average the difference
between the two cards is imperceptible
and shows up in measurements but would
not be noticeable to an end user the 970
XTS 83 FPS result has it again about 11%
ahead of the 970 so that's pretty
predictable now to just highlight some
landmarks the 2060 ran at 25 FPS and
tied the RX 6600 the 6600 XT ran at 29
and the 360 ran at 31 FPS average at
1080p the 970s 104 FPS average allowed
it to finally start gaining some
distance on the 570 it's not a
meaningful swing at 6% improved but is
in favor of the 970 if AMD were $50
cheaper it'd be a very clear Victory
unfortunately for AMD a tie will often
still be decided in nvidia's favor by
most buyers especially mainstream but
also because of the complications of RT
and sofware suedes but still beating the
57 in this game is an achievement for
the 7 Starfield is up now tested at 4K
in this one the RX 970 ran at 63 FPS
average and roughly tied the RTX 470 TI
super the 970 outperforms the RTX 570 is
54 FPS average by 177% which is starting
to be wide enough that Nvidia needs to
be concerned if they weren't basically a
monopoly but we never know when the
first Domino Falls the 5070 TI Falls
below the 970 XT in this one and only
leads the non-xt by about 6 FPS hardly
enough to spend $200 more for the
proximity to the 480 and 480 super also
isn't great news for NVIDIA at 1440p the
970 ran at 96 FPS average and nearly
tied the 4070 TI super again the 570 TI
outperforms the 970 by a lame
5.4% with the 970 XT outperforming the
970 by 10% against the 570s 83 FPS
average the 970 leads it by 15% if the
570 weren't already in the grave we
would pronounce its impending demise we
might want the 970 to be a bit cheaper
just to see that balance for the times
it loses or is tied like in the next
game but even without that we can't deny
that AMD is putting up its best fight
against Nvidia in years at 1080p the 970
runs at 118 FPS average relative rank
hasn't moved much it leads the 570 by
14% here so the lead has slightly
reduced but it's still ahead the 970 XT
leads the 970 by 8% in DL 2 at 4K the
970 ran at 56 FPS average and kept
Lowe's remarkably close by at 50 and 41
but not in any more remarkable way than
all of its neighbors the game is Just
consistent the 970 ends up tied with the
5070 there's no difference between those
two and in these situations Nvidia will
generally be viewed more favorably by a
mainstream audience that's where the
price would come in or hopefully the
awareness of other results the 970 XT
leads the 970 by 11% so you'd be paying
9% more at MSRP for about 11% more
performance this is one of those games
where the 5070 TI pulled ahead of the
970 XT and a not noteworthy way so we
see some of that apply to the 970 and
the 570 at 1440p the 970 runs at 106 FPS
average and ties the 5070 again they're
within error of each other the 970 XT
out performs the 970 by 11% with the
5070 TI still ahead of the XT
generationally we'll just briefly
highlight the RX 6600 the 2060 and the
RTX 360 as reference points to some of
the most common jeps of past Generations
though should give you an idea to the
performance gains cyber Punk is up now
this one has generally been for AMD in
the past but it's harder for it with
rage racing we'll start with rise
testing at 4K the results are thus far
positive we already knew that the 970 XT
outmatched the 55070 ti but now the 970
is nearly tying the 480 that's just
embarrassing for nvidia's last gen uh I
don't know what you call it a mid-range
posed as a false Flagship GPU as
compared to a $550 video cardart the 970
technically outperforms the 7900 XT as
well though is basically tied and the
lead over the 50 7 is 15% again at 1440p
the 970 now Falls slightly below the 700
XT so they've traded places as
resolution came down and the 570 has
also gotten closer the 970 is now about
11% ahead of the 570 rather than 15%
before the 970 XT leads the 970 by 11%
and the 570 TI slightly in Phantom
Liberty at 1080p now the 970 landed at
148 FPS average allowing the 7900 XD to
maintain its slight lead the Improvement
in the 970 over the 50 5070 is now down
to 7% from 15% at 4K originally if we
dropped it down to 360p based on this
trend Nvidia might actually pull ahead
like unironically I did that math that's
about where they should cross over so
great it's just like they've wanted
maybe that's the push for dlss R tracing
is up next this is where AMD has
invested heavy effort with its
architecture but all of it has been to
try and catch up Nvidia was so far ahead
in some games that AMD just won't be
able to catch them at all scenario the
real question is how much closer do they
get this time we'll start with amd's
worst case which is Blackmouth Wukong
but now with raay tracing and at 4K with
upscaling the 970 ran at 26 FPS average
here so outdoing the 3070 TI but below
the 380 from 2020 the 3080s original
MSRP was around $700 although that
really only held for a week or two
before Co era scalping went crazy the
970 XT outdoes the 970 by 14% here this
is too low of a frame rate to be
playable but but we do the test for
relative scaling and percent scaling the
570 crushes the 970 here holding a 57%
lead over the AMD GPU the 570 TI scaling
over the 970 XT was better and nearly
80% but 57% is still huge for the 570
over the 9070 if you want to play black
myth with ra tracing like we said last
review you basically only buy Nvidia
lows are where Nvidia will struggle the
most for some scenarios with the 570
vram capacity in this particular test
we're not hitting vram saturation during
the testing however we have shown
instances where the 570 hits saturation
with heavy workloads and high
resolutions leading to heavy stutter
like in the cyberpunk RT 4K scenario
yesterday at 1440p upscale the 970
pushed 47 FPS this gave the 970 XT about
a 6 FPS lead nearly tied the 380 and
outperformed the 3070 TI and 7900 XTX
notably the improvement over the 7900
XTX shows that AMD has actually executed
on its RT performance uplifts but
unfortunately for am D the 570 remains
Superior with the 73 FPS average it
leads to the 970 by 55% that's huge at
1080p the 970 measured at 67 FPS average
and pushed past the 380 the 970 XT leads
by 9% the 570 leads the 970 by 46% so it
has slightly reduced but still an
unbeatable lead Dragon do 2 with Ray
tracing is next tested at 4K first we
would play Dragon Dogma with Ray tracing
uh for this lineup it's not as heavy we
measured the 970 at 56 FPS average
giving the 970 XT a lead of 9% the 480
isn't much past that so for as close as
these cards are they are also very close
to the 480 and the 480 super the 570
trails in this one giving the 970 a lead
of 15% at 1440p the 970 gets dangerously
close to nvidia's 570 TI which failed to
pass the 970 XT in the previous review
the 570 TI leads the 970 by 9% the same
same lead as the 970 XT has against it
the 570 non TI is down at 83 FPS average
creating a 133% lead for the 970 this
chart has entries for the 6700 XT and
other prior gpus so if you want to pause
for those you can check them out at
1080p the 970 ran at 119 FPS average and
led the 7900 XT by a few frames per
second the lead over the 507s 107 FPS
average was 11% the 970 XT has reduced
lead over the non XT at this resolution
now just 6% ahead of the cheaper card
dlight 2 with up scaling at 4K is up now
this time with r tracing the 970 XT
leads the 970 by a higher than average
lead of 160% here the 970 ends up below
the 570 in this one also with the 570
producing a lead of 9% over amd's most
relevant card at 1440p the 970 runs at
78 FPS average and gives the 970 XT a
lead of about 10 to 11 FPS the 970 xt's
prior 16% lead is now reduced to 14% the
570 is also reduced to a 4% lead from a
9% lead at 4K the 970 was really
struggling with that 4K resolution
though finally for this game 1080p puts
the 570 at just 1 FPS ahead now so
basically margin of error the 970 XT
leads the 970 by 133% in Resident Evil 4
with r tracing and at 4K upscale the 970
held a 104 FPS average and outperformed
the 470 TI super and 570 the Boost over
the 570 is 14% here the 970 XT ran 12%
higher frame rate than the NX XD with
the 5070 TI basically tied with that
this chart has a lot of cards lower down
the stack like the 2060 3060 2070 and
6700 XT for past generation comparison
at 1440p upscaled the 970 ran at 162 FPS
average and roughly tied the prior 7900
XT the 970 XT was 11% ahead of the non
XT here with the non XT ahead of the 570
by 9% cyber Punk is up last one of the
two heavier titles we use for RT we
tested this one at two groups of
settings Ultra and medium chosen because
Nvidia gains a disproportionate
Advantage at Ultra medium meanwhile
pushes them closer together that gives
us the full picture at 4K and RT Ultra
just a stress test it for relative
scaling the 970 ran at 18 FPS that's
obviously unplayable but this makes the
point we made in our 5070 review which
is that there are scenarios where the
0.1% lows on the 5070 can suffer in a
big way we pointed this out in the last
two reviews but that's because they're
indicating to us that underneath those
lows which really are just meant to be
an indic they're not the problem they
point to the problem which is spiky and
erratic frame Time Performance this is
caused by exceeding vram limitations on
the 5070 which simply isn't equipped
enough to deal with these problems at 4K
medium the 970 boosted up to 24 FPS no
change and how playable it is or isn't
but even this lighter weight workload is
too much for the 570 fe's capacity which
you can see in its lows again the 970 XT
leads the 970 by 15% here one of the
higher percent increases reducing the
resolution helps reach playable frame
rates the 1080 P RT Ultra result has the
970 at 61 FPS average against the 970 XD
71 that's a relatively large Advantage
as a percentage of 16% for the 9070 XT
the 570 ran at 64 FPS here out doing the
970 by just 5.7% finally the cyberp punk
1080p medium results put the 970 at 81
FPS average roughly tying the 700 XTX
this also puts it above the 3080 the
5070 ran at 81.9 FPS average and lows
were within error of the 90 70 there's
no distinct advantage in lows for the
970 here average is the same which is a
major positive for AMD when considering
its previous Rd deficit we're moving on
to power and efficiency testing now
which looks at both the total power
consumption of the device during the
test and the frame rate the end result
is that we can calculate the efficiency
and performance for wat it's actually a
really exciting task for the 9070
specifically an f124 at 4K and with rt
AMD has exceptional performance these
are only showing two decimals but more a
processed for the bar width the 970
roughly tied the 480 super and 590 Fe as
the most efficient GPU in the suite here
the 570 was at 0.17 FPS per watt giving
the 970 an advantage of 24% it's a huge
swing in its favor the 970 XT was closer
to the 570 here at 1080p but with the
same settings in game the 970 again ends
up just behind first place it's tied
with the 570 TI and just behind the 0.64
result of the 580 the 970 XT burns more
power and although its performance is
better the trade-off favors the 970 here
the 570 ends up way down the ranks at
0.55 here Final Fantasy 4K is up next
this is one of amd's weaker showings
given its limited performance scaling in
Final Fantasy 14 at 4K the 970 pulled
224 Watts during this test when measured
at the pcie cables and the slot the 570
pulled 10 watts more but had better
efficiency from its higher performance
the end result is that the 970 outdid
the 7900 XT for efficiency but gave the
5070 a lead of about 18% for reference
the 970 XT pulled 310 Watts here roughly
matching their tdps at 1440p the 970
ranked at 0.56 FPS per watt with a total
224 watt draw that has the 4060 as more
efficient the b570 is slightly less
efficient and the 7800 XD as slightly
less efficient also the Nvidia 570 is
0.65 FPS per watt result out does the
970 again here but we'll see if that
persists outside of amd's weakest
rasterization title Dragon stock with
two with rt shows exceptional efficiency
for the 97 7 at 224 Watts again and 0.42
FPS per watt it's looking pretty good
overall the performance is slightly
lower than that of the 970 XT but the
reduction in power really puts it in a
better spot on the efficiency curve it
seems like this is more of the so-called
sweet spot for power to Performance the
570 is down at 0.36 FPS per watt despite
pulling 231 watts in Starfield at 1440p
the 970 is less impressive than an F1
and dragon's dog with two but still
overall good its result was 0 .43 FPS
per watt a large Improvement on the 970
XT 0.34 the 970 ties the 570 which is a
problem for NVIDIA because efficiency
was one of nvidia's Main benefits with
570 TI against the 970 XT so if andd is
starting to chip that away uh that's bad
news for NVIDIA that's one of the key
things that they've kind of stood upon
for being more expensive in the past
that's it then first of all credit to
the 970 for being one of the most power
efficient cards on our charts now it's
like basically tied at the top in a few
of those charts not all of them but uh
it's looking better there now in our 970
XT review we said that AMD made the
right choice for pushing for higher
performance on the XT rather than
pulling back some of its power budget to
get better efficiency so that was kind
of the trade-off that any silicon
manufacturer has they can choose
efficiency with lower performance or
they really push the power envelope and
get kind of past the peak point on the
efficiency curve so the XT goes past
that point and uh the 979 XT pulls it
back looks really good in the charts
which is uh actually really important
for AMD because that is one of the
things on the bullet list of reasons you
buy on video without checking
performance If you're sort of a
mainstream buyer and they're chipping
away at that now the reasoning the
difference is so big against the XT is
because it seems that the 970 XT just
pushes past the peak of that curve to
maintain the clocks and that CU count
necessary in order to be actually pretty
competitive whereas the 970 it gets most
the benefit of the architecture and has
a slightly reduced CU count they pull
the power drop back and AMD also gets
the benefit from because they've reduced
the power draw by 80 Watts on the 9070
for out a box uh they can create more of
a gap between their own XT and their non
XT so they're kind of playing it from
both angles which is what they need to
do the 970 XT ends up ahead of the 970
by about 9 to 12% in most of the games
we tested with the 5070 generally giving
the 970 a lead in several games Dragon
stock with two at 4K was playable on
both but the 970 had about a 14%
advantage over the 5070 the 970 also led
the 570 by about 15% in cyberpunk
rasterized at 4K with the 970 XT ahead
of the 970 by 12% there remains one
breakout for the 570 and Final Fantasy
something we talked about in our XT
review but beyond that for rasterization
the 970 is ahead in basically every
scenario Ballers Gate 3 even showed a
large benefit at 4K for the 970 versus
the 5070 since we're far away from the
CP bottleneck in rate tracing at 4K the
970 XT ended up around 9% to 19% higher
frame rate than the 970 though that 19%
number is based on a low frame rate but
even still 17 is the next highest
percentage 1440p and 1080p weren't that
different and can be found in the chart
section earlier as for the 5070 in RT
and 4K the 970 Beat It by 15% Dragon
stock with 2 8% in f124 6 to 7% in
cyberpunk 14% in Resident Evil 4 now
these summary charts as a reminder these
are are calculated as percent
improvement from the 570 to the 970 the
thing to be aware of is that because the
math is calculated as a percent
improvement from 570 to 970 uh those
negative numbers are sort of going in
the opposite direction so the really
proper way to do this would be to
calculate them all individually as
percent Improvement for the highest
minus the lowest uh but we just spent 30
minutes doing that so you can find that
in the rest of the charts earlier back
to the percentages this is the reason we
don't like these summary charts
generally but the black myth result if
you to calculate in the same direction
then it ends up being 57% improved for
the 5070 over the 970 so that would be
the more comparable number to the rest
of the positive numbers we're looking at
the 970 lost in black myth and DL 2 with
rt at 1440p and RT the same loss as
exist so this puts the non XT and the XT
in a similar position to what we saw
with the 7800 XT and the 7700 XT or the
7900 XT and the 700 XTX the Gap is small
enough that most people will basically
upsell themselves to the XT model in
this case weirdly nvidia's own fumbles
have sort of made the proximity of these
two cards less of a problem than it
might otherwise have been because From
amd's perspective it's AMD or AMD they
probably don't really care that much
which of AMD you buy but the XT makes
more sense than a 5070 does assuming the
MSRP for both the 5070 is already mostly
irrelevant Nvidia strengths of its dlss
Ray reconstruction reflex all those
remain of course but the bells and
whistles just we don't think are good
enough on the 5070 to outweigh the 970
or the XT the biggest strength Nvidia
has is Cuda so for applications where
you need Cuda acceleration the software
we use for a lot of the production work
we do it's all Cuda accelerated so
doesn't really matter we're we're in for
the 490s or the 309s or whatever uh
because that's just what makes our work
go faster for things like video editing
but from a gaming standpoint the 970 and
the 970 XT have really kicked the ass of
the 5070 to be fair though the 5070 it
was like it was kind of off to the side
kicking its own ass and then the 970s
came in and they're like oh that looks
fun and they joined in I want to thank
all of you for coming today so
um I don't know anyway uh that's it for
this one thanks for watching subscribe
for we're going to talk more about the
pricing over the next few days as we get
a chance to see it unfold so might be
Harbor news might be Standalone I don't
know yet uh but yeah that's going to be
it I'm going to go to sleep thanks for
watching to directly support our review
use and the huge amount of effort it is
to push through this many this quickly
plus all the other chaos go to store.
Gamers access.net you can help us out
directly with our reporting all the work
we do these days is majority funded by
the audience and from your support on
both the store and patreon and on the
store you can get some cool stuff like
PC Building anti-static mod mats you can
also grab a project and soldering mat or
one of our copper plated stainless steel
me mugs our coach packs pretty cool too
check it out on the store there's a lot
of cool stuff there uh dice kits too
thanks for watching thanks for the the
support it's been fun to work on
something this cycle that's not just a
complete train wreck so uh we'll have
some more stuff coming up soon and we'll
see you all next time